hurricane Ian may be making landfall in
Florida quite literally as we speak I
hope every one of our viewers in the
areas that are getting hit and we have a
lot of viewers in those areas are
um heeding the precautions evacuating if
you've been indicated that if it's been
indicated that you should evacuate Fox
News propagandist Tucker Carlson is
saying that hurricanes are a scam
we are going to take a look at a clip of
Tucker's show from last night let's take
a listen
so you hate to Hype hurricanes because
it's just a staple of TV and everyone's
kind of onto the skin but there's a
legitimately large hurricane barreling
toward the Gulf Coast of Florida tonight
hurricane bigger than we've seen in more
than 100 years the foremost hurricane
predictor in this country many people
Vie for the title but this man may take
it joins us after the break
yeah so listen I I don't know whether
Tucker is saying that worrying about
hurricanes is generally a scam or that
the media coverage of the hurricane
industrial complex is a scam
but it is genuinely scary that fox
news's business model in many ways is
tell our viewers that they are being
lied to about lots of different things
that will actually keep them safer right
don't get the vaccine
don't take precautions on covid there's
no climate change hurricanes are a scam
now the most charitable interpretation
of what Tucker Carlson is saying here is
the way that media Outlets
spend days covering hurricanes sending
reporters to stand in the wind and the
rain and the entire thing the disaster
porn videos that that is a scam
that would be the most charitable
interpretation of what Tucker is saying
and if that's the case his own network
is one of the greatest perpetrators of
that very scam because Fox News does it
all the time they will do the 24 7
hurricane coverage just like everybody
else so it's never really clear what
Tucker Carlson is saying and this is
kind of part of his game to always use
sort of coded language or to kind of
dance around issues in some way it's not
exactly clear what he means that the
scam is but the theme Here is Fox News
participates in whatever scam he's
talking about just as much as everybody
else and if you exclusively get your
news from Fox News you are more likely
to be receiving suggestions implicit or
explicit that you engage in behavior
that is quite literally putting your
life at risk and that is wacky we will
have all of these clips on our Instagram
make sure you're following us at
davidpackman show we will take a quick
break and be back to cover the growing
Republican Civil War as we get closer to
2024 Stay With Me
I have a really tough time finding dress
shirts I like they're either
uncomfortable or they're tight or
they're loose or hot or itchy and that's
why it's been so great to discover the
commuter shirts made by our fantastic
sponsor Rhone rhone's commuter shirt is
a reinvention of the men's dress shirt
it's the most comfortable dress shirt
I've worn Roan's comfortable four-way
stretch fabric provides the
breathability and the flexibility that
leaves you free to enjoy what life
throws your way could be a long day at
work could be brunch with the family
you're just going to be comfortable and
that's so important with rhone's wrinkle
release technology the wrinkles
disappear as you stretch and wear the
shirt which is very convenient and Rhone
is 100 machine washable so you can skip
the dry cleaning altogether I've had a
great experience with Rhone the shirts
are appropriate if you want to look nice
or somewhat formal
I rarely need to and they're just as
good as a comfortable t-shirt when you
want to relax or just move around in it
go to rhone.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman to get 20 off the most
comfortable shirt you'll ever own the
link is down below